All right. Welcome to the DDPS seminar everyone.
Before we introduce our invited speaker, let's
go over some rules and logistics. First of all,
please mute yourself during the talk. But if you
have questions, you can unmute and ask questions
or use chatroom to post your questions so that
we can address them in q&a session at the end.
Second, today's DDPS seminar is open to external
audiences there will no classify the question is
allowed. Finally, the talk today will be recorded
and uploaded in our YouTube channel. That's about
it. Now, let me briefly introduce our speaker
today. It is an honor to host Dr. Chu and Jiang
foo is an associate professor in the department
of mathematics at the University of Hong Kong. He
received his bachelor's degree and PhD degree in
mathematics from Ching Hua University Beijing,
China in 2006, and 2011, respectively. After
his graduation, he was a postdoctoral scholar
at Caltech from 2011 to 2015. He joined the
University of Hong Kong as an assistant professor
in 2015 and became an associate professor in 2021.
Dr. John's research interests our scientific
computation research topics include uncertainty
quantification, numerical numerical methods for
stochastic differential equations and stochastic
partial differential equations, and numerical
methods for partial differential equations arising
from quantum chemistry, wave propagation,
multiscale, multi scale, porous media,
nonlinear filtering, data assimilation
and stochastic fluid dynamics, very broad,
broad applications. Recently, he is
also working on deep learning methods
for solving stochastic differential equations and
partial differential equations. Today to one will
talk about deep particle learning invariant
measure by a deep neural network minimizing
Vassar Stein distance on data generated from
an interacting particle method. Please enjoy
an expected a wonderful talk. Before I press
the button, let me ask Dr. John, Dr. Chang,
a couple of questions, so that we get to know you
better and make this seminar somewhat informal.
All right. You ready? Yes. Yes, yes. Okay. So
obviously, you're passionate about mathematics,
especially differential equations in general. Is
there any moment in your life when you realize
that this is it? This is the field that I would
like to commit my career if you if you? Yeah,
yeah, that's a simple example, when I was the
junior student, before that, I fascinated about
a number theory. But I later on, I feel
that as the path was very boring, I mean,
I need to prove a lot of theory to realize my
dream as a number theory guy. So I, then there's a
professor gave a talk about scientific computing,
I realized I was fascinated about that talk,
the professor can use scientific computing to
simulate many real world application problems.
So after showing that talk, I feel that scientific
computing is more interesting than number theory.
So I changed my you know, real interest and
moved to this area that long ago, was second
question you, you are now interested in, in deep
learning these days? How? How do you think deep
learning will help for scientific computing? I'm
sure you're going to delve into it in today's
talk. But if you can summarize it in one or
two sentences, before you start your talk,
then last question. So I use this, I realized this
few years ago, like five years ago, before that,
I used the traditional tools to do scientific
computing, such as IBM FDM, Spectrum measured,
etc. And also UQ, such as like a stochastic
computing. But a few years ago, I realized
the deep deep learning approach can handle some
challenge apart in this area. That cannot be done
using traditional existing tools. So I invested
some time to explore this direction. Yeah,
sure. I'm sure you're gonna
show all of that in some,
some of them not all of them in
today's talk. Okay, this is yours.
Thank you for your very kind invitation
and In the introduction, so, dear audience,
good afternoon and also Good morning, maybe
equally evening, I don't know you're watching now,
but let's start this talk. So, this is a jewel,
i Today I will briefly introduce this work on so
called the D particle method, which the title is
very complicated, but I hope after this talk you
can have a take home message that means, we will
use this deep learning deep neural network tool
to learn the unit of measure or some distribution
is depends on some parameter. So, how to generate
into distribution that motivated about our periods
work we develop this local interacting particle
method to to to solve another problem. So, yes,
this is a long title, but, you remember this
word it will define the particle. So, this
is a joint work with my former PhD student,
Dr. giunti one right now, he's Assistant Professor
in NGO Singapore and also professor Jackson from
UC Irvine. Okay, let me start this talk. So,
today the talk I want to do this, first apart
is this. So, I briefly introduced the So, called
the interacting particle method for computing the
KVD from speed. So, this part is a little bit of
theoretical. So, that's the starting part of our
department code. Basically, I will tell you some
existing results before and the the motivation,
why we develop this department called method and
the second part is more related to this talk is I
tell you, I will tell you how to use the particle
to learn if you are married and the sad part is
some numerical result, I will show you a summary
that application with the particle in computing
TBBT can we be frost speed and also another
application a new learning at the can rating
this aggregation patterns in kilos ego chemo tech
system and also a byproduct of this department
call method is a way we find the efficient
method for computing optimal control problem
and conclusion. So, I hope you can follow me in
some key points. So, let's start the first part is
this interacting particle method. So, I hope I can
briefly introduce this part. So, before that, so,
let me tell you before the deep learning before
the machine learning part I work on this this So,
called the reaction diffusion advection equation
with the KVP nonlinear term this is the Ukrainian
wide SPD. So, this has has applications in in
studied fraud and propagation in complexity
the complete complex flow in many areas such as
turbulent compaction, chemical kinetics etc. So,
people are interested in in this complicated PDE
what is the propagation speed for the fraud. So,
but the this a PDS are nonlinear why because if
it's not linear nonlinear PDE is difficult to
handle. So, people will linearizing and the study
the minimal foreigner speed okay. So, in the in
the literature the for the front KBB from speed,
if the flow if the flow is well structured such
a regular or periodic or phony random like Gothic
motion is a lot more steady forever when the flow
is chaotic, such as ABC flow or Kamala flow there
were less studied. So, we started this use our
measure. So, as I said, nonlinear APD is difficult
to handle that people are linearizing So, here is
some theoretical result. So, for if the velocity
is the time a study does not depend on time. So,
the minimum from speed in any direction E is
given by this version of for C star is this
is a here this A mu lambda is the principal
Eigen value of this elliptical operator. See,
this, this part is a linearized for for the kbps
are this nonlinear nonlinear operator nonlinear
linear writing. So, essentially you need to solve
this difficult PDE eigenvalue problem You get a
principle eigenvalue principle eigenvalue is the
biggest one with with the biggest real part. So,
you solve this Eigenvalue problem and you take
care of this length and you get a minimal fraud
speed. So, in the literature people use you know
every year or spectral method to solve this clever
you know, if the dimension is a three, it's ready
problem and the compilers more or the pipeline
number is very large. Solving this Eigenvalue
problem is a challenge for for sorry for for mass
people, if we don't have a large computer to solve
this in 3d is a challenge, but if you are in that
working lab, you have a very huge computational
resource solves ready problems okay. Okay. And all
right. Another case before the velocities field is
time dependent, here this period servers law firms
still exist. Now, you need to solve this parabolic
type eigenvalue problem okay, that again you get
the principal eigen value and you take this
you still can get the minimal from speed along
direction E. So, here you have one mode dimension
means that time okay. So, for solve this parabolic
type I know in the literature only to do one
study to to the physicality or to to the again,
if these three and even COPPA is more, solving
this principle eigenvalue is also expensive. So,
that's a motivator for us to develop a some
practical method. So, like laundry and type
method to to solve this problem. So, before
your work with John Tiana Jack were developed
some structure preserving particle methods for
computing effective diffusivity in 2d and 3d. So,
we have a period of experience in solving 3d
problems. So, this motivates us to develop this
particular method to solve 3d problem killing the
product from the the problem. So, the idea very
is following the way So, this this Eigen prismatic
value is essentially the layup know for exponents
of this parabolic type TD, so, let's measure
the growth or decay of this system Alright,
so, to to come to this we need this So,
called the framework has formula okay. So,
here you look this up a operator has a straight
path, if your action the action or the reaction
or potential. So, for you we can do a split with
the beta Operator A into L and say Here l is a
diffusion advection part and the seeds potential
part. So, from the diffusion part we can construct
as the system like this as the system then
according to this a very beautiful elegant
framework has a formula, the principal eigenvalue
have this beautiful representation here. So, so,
that means, you can compute that for this
a principal Eigen value using this famous
formula. That means you will solve this SD, you
solve this SD or the plugging in this potential
part. And you'll take a listen just operation
and you can get this press bag of value. So,
you have another word, this the same Mac has a
formula provider alternative approach to compute
the principal Eigen value. So, mathematically
there's a very beautiful and elegant,
clever in computing part to conclude that
this is not stable. Why? Because here you
have a lot of exponential law, this kind of
thing. Because if you do scientific computing,
this exponential operator is very
difficult to handle. Because there's,
you're you're changing the value of very large
and very small. So this will bring difficulty
in numerical computation. So this formula
is a mathematical it's a very beautiful,
but computationally it's not a very, you know,
uniform. So we we don't have to this approach.
So, oh, yeah, that's my comment.
A comment here directly using this
framework has formula Oh, seven is unstable.
So how to address this issue. So remember,
in in the linear linear algebra course, we, you
know, there's a period first look at the power
method or power iteration to compute a principal
eigenvalue matrix. So it's actually a matrix,
you randomly generate a vector, you multiply
a with this vector, and then normalize it,
and then multiply A again and normalize. So as
this iteration going on, and there's a power
iteration going on, you will get your principal
eigenvalue and also the principal source. Okay,
so that's a linear Merkel linear order. So, here
we have a similar idea. So, this is not developed
by us in the literature, there are many many
research we just do this so called the famous
tax signing group to to compare the purse bag
value. So, essentially, you can view this as
the power method applied all this merits okay.
So, so, yeah, in this same kind of semi group,
we defined this we need to defy this evolution
operator p this and also a weighted counterpart
is PC. So weighted means weighted by the potential
seat okay. So, the equation eight and the equation
I have this building blocks for female cats and
the group here, this operator a pile murderers,
murderers, okay, and the pets function has
functions. So, you can easily verify this the P
and the PC or the infant, if it has more generator
for L and eight respectively. So yeah, here
equipped with definition p and a PC, we can define
this Mac has operator feisty, is this. So it's a
very long it's a very complicated but uh, you can
just view this as a power measure, okay? You do
this evolve and normalize, evolve and normalize.
So, that's so called the female cat semi group,
and you can verify this operator satisfy the
semi group property. And in in definition, you
can choose any time interval, but in in computing,
we will choose the period. So if the flow has a
period that he either way, we'll do the iteration
every period. But if the flow isn't steady does
not depend on time you can choose the artificial
time is t equal one or t equal to add artificial
period period and you can define this a female cat
semi group in this pattern okay. So, that there is
a very beautiful property for for this female cat
semi group zero. So, if you're Operator A has a
spectral gap spectral gap means that the printer
eigenvalue the biggest one with a real pop and the
other parts that remain remaining power and the
how this is natural gas then this a female cat
semi group iteration will call Archer to HCU Marta
mega, you will see in this rate exponentially
fast, okay, depends on the spectral gap. So that
means if your spectral gap is larger, and you're
converge faster, it just like power method, you're
the biggest of the ratio of the second eigenvalue
over the first eigenvalue, if this ratio is more
than your current fast okay. So, a lot here when
you apply for any measure. So, remember, this
is very important for any new any merit new as
your initial CAS you do this iteration and this
will Karachi to the UART a very new thing you can
actually fast okay. So, so once you get this you
Marta, Mara and you'll see you can compute your
principal Eigen value in this formula essentially
is kind of like integration of some value with
respect to your your bearer okay. So, so, this
computer prints back our value prop this okay,
this our foundation for the interacting particle
better alright. So, this is theoretical part. Then
next few slides I will briefly tell you how to
implement this as a car limitation on matter. So,
in computation, we need to, you know, do some
new record use this calculation for the SD. So,
we'll develop very simple Allah Mariappa scheme
to compute that s e associated with operator L
like this okay this so, this some alright that by
the way just ties the the female cat semi group
uses particles okay. So, here this is a test time
distillation and here is timeless tradition one
more thing, remember this a new is any mirrors
or distribution. So, So, theoretically you can
study any better clever in computation part,
you cannot evolve beggars, we can only you know
approximate this matter by particles, okay. So,
for example, you do sample for any initial mirror,
you generate your own particle to vote, so
let's say this, where this one, you'll generate
a URL for any initial meta meal you generate and
particles, you use this empirical distribution to
approximate the initial barrier. Okay, this a
unparticle, that's the name we need unparticle
Okay. So, let me okay, the quickly through the
algorithm, the idea of the following look at this
diagram. So, initially you generate n particles
according to the initial initial distribution,
then you you evolve this. So, you evolve this
particle accordion this SD, okay, remember,
my period is a T, okay T, capital T, and we need
to do this iteration every period from n minus one
T to NT. So, whereas in each period, we partition
the T into M part. So, yeah, so, so within this
small, small event period, we solve this SD
with a timestamp delta t. Okay, so we solve
as the y part. And the way to do this is we come
here the way to do resampling, the resampling. The
here we use the resampling so that we can control
the variance. Okay, so where's the in one period
within one period? Yeah, from S to from zero to
t, we will do this one part we solve SD that will
compete away Tanoto resampling. So, when you
finish this one, one period, I do it again. So
totally, we need a small time iteration. So small
is a large, small is a large. So this is a whole
algorithm. All right. So once you're finished
this iteration, so gradually, you can compute this
increased mass, change your mass, so called the E,
and then plugin. So eventually, you have numerical
solution. So numerical formula to compute the
principal eigenvalue. So this part is a little
bit of fat, sorry, please forgive me, if I know
something that's clear. And you can ask me later.
So essentially, we do this, we solve as the one
part and we compute the weight under resampling.
That solve as the resampling. So we finish one
period and continue continue. So there's a needle
a lot of iteration, there's not a lot of iteration
until, until this empirical distribution, Karachi
to the US America. So we do this iteration, many,
many times on here, this empirical distribution
of the particle Karachi to the North America.
Okay, so that we get to the principal eigenvalue.
I'll quickly pass this commercial analysis
part because if you are really interested in
you can email me or you can also find them our
paper and the DAX I moved to the particle part.
All right, I moved I skip this convergence
analysis part. The main result is we can prove
we can prove this theory that the left hand
part is the our numerical study OSHA or the
right apart is the team that prints by value.
And then we come through the convergence error
analysis, they have this two part error pathway is
this this depends on how quickly how quickly your
iteration can converge the universal mirror. And
this part is where we use this operators bleating,
olavarria boss team to solve the SD we have
this time dependent error. Okay, so that's a
Coronavirus analysis I quickly pass it. Let's
let me quickly show you some results. First,
why is the 2d is ready we can compute
the TBD front speed. Remember, you know,
imperious approach people solve eigenvalue problem
by FDM or FDM or spectral method. But here we use
a particular method for for 2d, it's okay but
the for 3d desktop or laptop, solving this 3d
eigenvalue problem is expensive clever use the
particle method is easy to the 3d we can verify
the colors the correct answer is a better than
Dallas's that means our analysis not as sharp in
the competition we can achieve will commerce rater
figure that one out okay. Okay. Dependence on the
amplitude of velocity field. Also time dependent
the flow see to the timing dependent flow,
you need to solve the Parabolica type eigenvalue
problem. So, for for our approach, it's easy.
Okay, one more thing I want to comment is for
for this time of demand and the flow, for timely
manner flow, you need to solve a parabolic type
solve a parabolic type eigenvalue problem, you
introduce one more dimension, okay. However, for
SD. For SD, you'd only it's a it's a computational
cost is the same as before, because your tape term
depends on time It's okay. You're just again you
solve the same same type as the Okay. So that's
definitely it's our measure the current handle
this time that impact dependent flow or steady
flow easily easily okay. And also with other
failures, they also interested in the dependent
of flow of France did on the strength of flow,
we studied this. So, essentially the question
is what is the power between your say star
and a star eight okay. So, for the for the to the
settler flow people can prove say Star is how this
power a to the power wire overflow and in for the
effective diffusivity is this. So, they have this
relationship means the from speed and the effect
you do safety have there's a power relationship.
So, when verify this is true include the salary
flow and we also verify numerically fine, this
is a still true first ready, Kogelo flow, but no
proof no proof. So, the PD expert can invest this
later. Let me okay. So, next as a byproduct I have
said before in our interacting particle method, we
need to evolve particles empirical distributions.
So, for example, here for this a 2d Cellular flow
case, we need to say 200,000 particles 200 solid
particles to you know this empirical distribution
see, if you change the sigma sigma you can view
as the diffusion parameter if your differentiation
parameter the covariance more than your event
a matter developers are much sharper gradient
subgradient or more concentrate I'll say this
way if a sigma is large, you're in North America
is very small. However, if your sigma is a
small gradually becomes the more you can see
the universe the merrier gradually concentrate in
some regions so that your development some sharp
ingredient gradient Okay, so that means, okay
here for the periodical time independent of law
in North America has some theoretical structure
periodicals. Roger Okay one last example is here
again you can see for this mixing flow to the
periodical mixing flow if you're decreased sigma,
if you're decreased sigma from two from one two
to the minus five, you can see the distribution
well generators on the sharp sharp gradient sharp
gradient okay. So, guys this a very important
part. So, that means so, imagine let me say this
you you want to come here this KBB frolunda For
six different sigma for this a bigger one you
choose so, your initial distribution is a uniform
distribution you may need the tensile Sorry 1000
iterations to get this you want to marry forever
for this small sigma case use use data from the
initial distribution again uniform distribution
you may need a consulted or more than 10,000
iterations to get an inverted mirror. So,
so that means for this small segment cases
it's a you need a more and more iterations
okay. Let me say again, if you start from initial
uniform distribution for this last one, you may
need a very few iteration to get this in your
conveyor. However, for this small sigma cases,
because the amount of error is communicated
has on the shopper gradient, you need the more
and the more iterations to get this, you learn
better. So that means your algorithm become more
and more expensive, more and more expensive.
Okay, so here's the question how to reduce this
cost or how you learn some distribution, how to
learn the dependence of this distribution on this
parameter sigma. Okay. So that's the motivation
we developed for this particular lesson. We Yeah,
we we developed what is the particle method
to learn and to generate new order measures
for our problem okay, let's let's say this
way, we based on based on this distributions,
we can use this as a training data, we we train a
neural network, which when you learn your network
that color and generate the dependence of this
in order to measure all these parameters sigma,
okay. So, if you can do this you can even let me
show you a picture here. So, guys, for example,
yeah, look at this picture, we have us for a
group of data this figure might become a very
small a bigger to small you can see this deviation
also become a little bit concentrated. So,
based on this training data, we can we can
learn this dependence. So, after this learning
we we input a a smaller sigma we input a smaller
sigma okay. And this is the grant a true event a
murder and this is predicted in North America by
the neural network Okay. Although this is not a
very accurate compare with Corolla true however,
however, if you use this as a input as initial as
the initial distribution for our Inter interacting
particle method, we can quickly quickly converge
to this true ground truth okay, otherwise,
otherwise, we need a uniform distribution,
which we only have a uniform distribution as the
initial initial data, so that neither more and
more iterations to get this growth to your
marriage. Okay, I hope I tell you this idea
clearly. Okay. So, let's meet started the second
part is so called the particle part. So, how
to how to learn how to learn the dependence or
distribution of parameter, we use this technique,
deep learning technique. So, essentially, you
know, cable and a to diffusion mu and mu, we want
to construct this port transport transport map,
such as the map Omega to another. Okay, so that's
a theoretical part to measure the distance between
two men error or distribution, we need a we need
to construct some merit function. Some commonly
used the why is so called the Wasserstein distance
wasn't a distance like this. Alternatively, we
can choose like KY directors, although it's not
a distance, but we can, you know, we can use KY
directors as well, and also the Hellinger distance
as well. But in our first paper we, we chose,
there wasn't a distance because that's why it's
popular or they're popular. Okay. So, there's
a distance in our case, we started people to I
mean to distance to was the Wasserstein distance
Okay, in the computing we cannot handle matters,
we have to approximate the matters by empirical
distributions like we approximate this letter
by this samples, okay, the position x y and y and
the Oxo in committee computation, we cannot handle
this a joint distribution joint distribution,
we can approximate the joint distribution by
the same token the double is casting a matrix. So,
this gamma is a matrix n by n essentially for for
every j some is some is one and for every i that
some is a of J is a one and all the elements are
now that q so, it's a double A stochastic matrix
essentially we're used as a doubly stochastic
matrix to to approximate any element in this
joint diffusion distribution All right. So,
after this digitization we approximate this also
the distance by these particles particles okay.
So, add here this our loss function because the
deep learning machine learning we need to some we
need to construct the loss function loss function
like a ping deep rate Sorry, sorry, not the police
like a ping you need a loss function here, we
in our particle we also need the loss function
is the here based on this was that distance
here the summation means parameter depends on
parameter. Okay, there's our loss function loss
function. So, wait wait wait Okay guys, here the
story, we need to base our training data we need
to minimize this loss function loss function. So,
here there are two parts, this F peseta this part
is is parametrized by a deep neural network. So,
we need to use this as g d to to minimize this
problem either has a comma ij the other part is
the weight or the cost function in the optimal
control optimal transport optimal transport. So,
essentially, we we have to minimize the toolpath
Why is the way other Just where are the charts
the weights in the neural network to reduce
this loss function and also we need to adjust
this cost function cost function or w comma
ij to minimize this loss function, okay, we
do this alternatively means we fix the gamma, we
fix the gamma and the way we use SGD to minimize
this to adjust the weights in the neural network
setup. And we fix the setup and the way use the
linear programming or some optimal transportation
algorithm for the drastic gamma one alternatively,
okay, until we minimize this loss function,
so, the idea is a little bit boring, we skip
this. And one more thing I also tell you is if
you're solving an optimal control problem, so,
if the size is small, you can see essentially that
is a linear programming problem, you can use like
a simpler compressor or interior point method to
solve. However, in our case, we have N particles,
this URL can be large such as 100 or 1000. So very
large, so in this case, the linear programming
also become expensive, such as the simplex method
or, or the interior point method become expensive.
So how to reduce this part? I'm a computational
guy. I use this idea for mathematical notation.
So, also called a mini batch method. So the idea
is very simple, you know, you don't do the, you
don't use the all the point that simultaneously
we randomly choose m low and M column here,
we we randomly choose m low and the M column and
the way pick this sub matrix. As we solve this
sub problem, for the sub problem, we can use
some existing solver like a linear programming
simplex to measure other existing solver to solve
this linear programming problem the for the other
weights on total weight with don't change okay.
So, you can view this as a mini batch method fine,
but also you can view this as a Tamati combination
METHOD Idea fine. So, we solve this iteratively
okay. So, we we are later we in our dollar
paper, we prove this measure the coverage is
covered all right. So, this is our network very
simple, very simple network, we have this So,
called The Power net to deal with a parameter.
So, here x is a petition and the ITAR is another
parameter. So, you can use this as the sigma
time or other parameters in your problem,
we have this simple par net to train a neural
network recently, we are using some diffusion
model based network to improve our performance
Okay, some new markers out. So, first one is so,
can you learn some this mapping from a uniform
distribution to a normal distribution depends on
sigma the sigma here in the various various So,
we can get some lot we can possibly learn this
mapping okay that you know we in our first apart
we have this TDP for our speed of propagation,
we have a the in particle empirical sorry
interacting particle Lacerte So, we can
generate several groups of particle distributions.
So, based on this distribution, we can learn and
train that the particle the internet is already
the network so, that they can learn the dependence
of the immortal murderer or Seagull okay. So,
how this in North America depends on sigma Okay,
you'll see as sigma sigma becomes the more
this distribution become more concentrated
and the upper part is the ground truth and the
second part is learned by our network okay. So,
this is our training data and this is some
kind of extrapolation. So, I said again,
although this predictive distribution by a neural
network is not a perfect however, this can provide
a pre conditioner or initial distribution for
the in enacting particle method. So with this
distribution, you start your iteration quickly
you can correct so the true you are tomorrow.
Okay. Okay, one more application that's a
one more application after our previous work,
we want to find the other application for the
particle method. This is the so called killer
sago sit chemotaxis system. This will provide
another application of our problem. So if you're
working in this area, you're familiar with
this PD. So let's a PD is used to model this
bout bacterias the rows of bacteria the row
is the density of the bacteria and the sea is
the density of some chemicals or food. So you're
really people solve the parabolic parabolic case
that's a Chilean challenge. And to simplify
the model, you you assume this is sea change
fast low. So you know to the UFC only approach
zero as they say become a you will be a PD elite
PD or you have a current function. You solve
this Olympic PD as a plugin here and you get
this so called the Macan Vela solve equation. And
also expert also want to add an extra advection
term into this PDE to study how the external
environment factor the The evolution that's the
low so the solve this problem okay. So, this so
called the McCain Villa solve PDE and you can have
this particle representation interacting particle
representation pay the kernel and the web is a
Brownian motion Okay, here are some easy will
fall for this one thing is this interacting
particle is expensive, because for each time you
need a unsquare iteration computational cost. So,
totally this entire team particle system is
expensive. Another thing is this green function
has a singularity will act as a GI Nexus
alright close okay. So, we we in our case,
we smooth this kernel, we smooth this kernel by
some smaller regularization term we added some
regularization term and the slaughters kernel and
the way we do this we use the particle method to
learn at the Generate aggregation pattern for
this tailor Seco system. Here let me show you
some results. So, first is A to D so, to D and B
is zero. So, in a PD literature people can prove
if your critical mass is bigger than eight Pi and
you have a final time blow up fan time below. So,
t equal one over eight is the solution we have
a lot. So, here I have several pictures to show
you see, my training data is all patella by
interacting particle measured from zero to 0.1
Okay. So, yeah, this reference reference means
this result is obtained by interacting particle
method. And the neural network output means this
results obtained by deep neural network. So, you
can say from zero 0.0012 0.1 This is the largest
time in training data. Okay, so, this rewind,
the training is fine. And based on training, you
can view it here as a parameter. So, we'll plug
in key equals 0.02 That is kind of extrapolation,
extrapolation and our network outputs and you know
produce some result close to some reference. So,
this kind of nearly blew up or singular behavior
singular behavior. So, here is a welcome comments
is this a particle base the bat method can learn
and the generator some nearly singular or blow
up behavior behavior okay. So, that's that's a
very beautiful path for the particle method or
okay here another example, I add this external
direction term v, the amplitude is parametrized
by eight, okay. So, there's some theory to prove,
if you add this external term, they can postpone
or not or avoid blow up blow up you can imagine
this you have a bacteria here you add some water
velocity along one direction and you can you know,
you know you you blow this bacteria to one
direction very low okay This will avoid or
postpone the plot. So, in this data here again
my training data is a from a equal tell to equal
100 Okay, equal 100 is largest a in the training
set okay However, after training, we can do some
predictions for example, what happened for a
is 150 We can do some kind of extrapolation,
extrapolation. So, this is the ground true either
this is predicted by our network kind of some
kind of close clever if you further increase
a you will get some not accurate result. So,
that means for for this a deep neural network
within a certain rate range, your explanation
is still okay. Why However, if you'll be out that
range, the installation the prediction role for
3d First Lady you will also have built for a dot
c equal to a call 100. See here, this a 130 is
also fish relation, because the in this example, a
equal 100 is the largest parameter in the training
data set. Okay, finally, one comment is we see
as a byproduct of this particular method, we,
we proposed the so called the mini batch, or
random blog coding the descendant method, so,
RPC D, let's say this here, sorry, this way,
you can call this as a mini batch, automatic
accommodation or random blog coordinate descent
method we'll choose how to choose this working set
M is important. Important if you're just randomly
choose m and your characters is not a very fast.
However, if you develop some indicator, and you
choose a better working set, you can accelerate
this random random blog community send the
message. So with RPC D, and the way you find
that this performance is comparable to a sinkhole
algorithm, here is some example. If you you
know, one d two d is ready, you want to map this
a uniform distribution to normal distribution,
you want to map this out your initial your initial
uniform distribution to this inverter Mara for
KBP. Okay, that's a, I have some training data,
okay, you can do this as optimal transportation
problem. We, we solve this by our ARP CD, and
also compare it with a sinkhole method. So here's
some results. If you're in a sinkhole method, you
need some you need this Anthropo regularization,
you have another parameter, if that parameter is
very large, the single algorithm is not accurate.
If that parameter is very, very small, the
single algorithm needed more iterations. However,
our arpc D is comparable to cinco aggregate seen
some some time it's better than cinco, I will
we're still working on this we are still
study this ARP CD our in our current paper.
So, okay, time is also almost up, let me
give a similar conclusion. In today's talk,
I gave two part first apart, I talked
about his interacting particle method
to compute the principal Eigen value of
the advection diffusion operation. So,
we can compute that from speed or RA da
equation with kimep nonlinear term then,
here for the parameter pack line numbers more
this method become expensive. So, this motivates
us to develop this particular method to learn and
generate the distributions. So, we were proposed
this the particle method to learn and generate the
universe the merits depends on parameter diffusion
parameter also called the Parkland number.
Although this method is a more very general,
we can extend it to more general contact or
deep learning, stochastic particles dynamics,
such as we were started is a killer signal, chemo
saqqaq chemotaxis system, we can learn how to
generate this aggregation patterns in 2d and 3d
kilos ecosystem. So right now, we are working on
other cases like parabolic parabolic cases or some
cancer growth models. So, so that's it. Thanks and
support the farmer, our founding agency and
other SFC from China. Thank you very much.
Thank you. Thank you so much for the
nice talk. Which one? It was very nice.
Let's have a q&a sessions. While you guys are
thinking about the questions I can ask first,
so yeah. You You said Well, looks like the
results, you know, Deep particle results.
You compare with a, in other reference
solutions. They look pretty similar,
but not quite same. Yeah, yeah. Yeah. So the
idea is you can plug those neural net outputs,
like the tip particle, I'll put
as the initial commission of
four. Yeah, this one. Yeah.
And then, you know, you
get the faster convergence.
Yeah.
If you can give us you know,
how fast it becomes, you know,
compared to the starting from the uniform? Oh,
that's a nice question. Yeah, that's the last
question we didn't do this before we Yeah,
the motivation is in in our peers
paper, if you so, the story this,
we want to start with the dependence of the the
front speed or on this sigma. So, so, that, so,
we want to get some power law, such as how this
frosty that depends on some parameter your system,
we all got this power law. So, in order to do
this, we need to choose different a parameter
given a parameter to compute the frost speed.
So we find that if you're you know, diffusion is
very small diffusion very small, your inverter
mehrerer given developer this sharp gradient,
so that is very expensive to to come here to this
from a uniform uniform distribution. So as small
become a small sigma become very, very slow,
you need the more and the more iterations. So
in order to reduce this cost, we will learn this
distribution. But how do you read a good question?
But how? How many savings we get? We didn't
do that test before. But definitely, you know,
definitely, you know, from from this figure, you
can see if you started from this one. So your your
goal is you want to do iteration to get this in
right America, right? If you're starting from
uniform diffusion, you may need like a 10,000.
Turns out, but the from this one, you may need
like a one solid, I guess, I guess I say, Okay,
I will test later. Yeah, that's a good question.
You're saying like factor of 10? performance gain?
I hope so. I'm sorry. But the
exact number I didn't test before?
It's okay. Thank you. You talked about her net?
For the parameterization? It's I haven't heard
of I mean, we been using hypernet people,
you know, to parameterize the neural net.
Okay. Although, do you happen to know, like
the difference between hypernet and permanet?
Sorry, I don't know, I will check your literature.
So this is before we do not before we solve TD
using nrps work, I also use a deep neural network
to solve a PDE interface problem. In that case,
there is no parameter dependence. So not not
this, we only have this the simple ResNet or
feed forward on that network. But here in this
project, we need to deal with a parameter.
But the how to how to add in this a parameter
into the network is a very, to us. It's a hot,
so we're trying several strategies.
And we finally found this one simple,
also helpful. So So we call this a pilot.
There's no special meaning just name by us. Oh,
oh, okay. So it's developer, you guys. Okay. Yeah,
it's lost, just by looking at the diagram and the
description you gave us. That sounds pretty
similar with the so called the hyperlapse. So,
okay, if you want to, you know,
take, you know, to some literature.
I see. Thank you. Thank you. So, I
will check. Yeah, okay. All right.
Any questions from audience? I
know it's a 5pm. In on Thursday,
here in California. Probably the
East Coast of the US. It's like,
what, eight or nine 8pm? Yeah, probably it's
trying to wrap up their their day. Well,
if there's no other question from all Yes,
let's thank our speaker for the nice talk.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Yes.
I mean, thank you so much for the wonderful
talk to you, man. Thank you. And yeah,
with that, we will wrap up. today's
seminar talk. Thank you. Okay.
Thank you. You're so bold to convey this
to us in the near future. Yeah, yeah.